Speaker 1: All right. I have to admit something
to you. I was completely wrong last year when
I wrote off this kuhnen conspiracy nonsense
as a minor passing, transient, insignificant
movement of no consequence whatsoever. And
my mistake was I overestimated the intelligence
of the American people. And this is not a
country where you can do that and end up correctly
assessing what's going on. When you overestimate
the intelligence of the American people, you
end up with Trump as president. Right? You
say even Republicans are never going to make
this guy their nominee, but they did. Well,
even Americans are not going to allow this
guy to become president like enough people
will come out to vote to, oh, he's the president.
You get burned and you end up very wrong.
And case in point. Q And on conspiracy theories
have caught on to the point that 20 percent
of Americans, one in five Americans believe
at least one. Q Kuhnen on conspiracy theory
right now, they may not consider themselves.
Q A Nonna's or whatever they call themselves.
They may not even know the origins of some
of these conspiracies, but at least 20 percent
of Americans believe one or more of these
conspiracy theories. PRR I. AFIC did a study
that was conducted during March. It was just
released late last week. 15 percent of Americans
agree with the Kuhnen statement that the United
States government, media and financial worlds,
quote, are controlled by a group of Satan
worshiping pedophiles who run a global child
sex trafficking operation. You go to the supermarket,
there's about 100 people in there, statistically,
15 of them believe this now. Of course, if
you're in Connecticut versus if you're in
Alabama, it's not going to be exactly 50 out
of 100. But on a national level, 20 percent
agree with the statement. There is a storm
coming soon that will sweep away the elites
in power and restore the rightful leaders.
20 percent believe that 15 percent of Americans
agree that, quote, because things have gotten
so far off track, true American patriots may
have to resort to violence in order to save
our country. And this relates to what I said
earlier about the right is increasingly vocal
and willing to just straight up call for violence
and say violence, guns, etc, may or will be
needed. This means that in total, if you talk
to five random people on the street, one likely
believes some of these ideas. Now, it's very
regionalized. If you do it in New York and
Massachusetts, it's not going to be one out
of five. If you go to Georgia and South Carolina,
it's going to be more than one out of five.
But on average, around the United States,
one in five people believes at least one of
these. I don't even want to call them theories.
Not surprising findings are that those who
trust far right news outlets like OCN and
Newsmax are more likely to believe this stuff.
White evangelicals are more likely to believe
the stuff, and Hispanic Protestants are more
likely to believe this stuff than Americans
in general. Now, the Hispanic Protestants
want is scary. You guys may remember that
right around the election I did a full season.
I think it was I think it was 13 episode 12,
13 episodes of a show like mine, but in Spanish
and it and it was American politics, but in
Spanish for Spanish speaking American residents.
And the amount of conspiracy stuff that I
got was was stunning. And even in some groups
I'm in WhatsApp groups and others Spanish
speaking groups, there is a lot of this stuff
shared disproportionately high. If you're
wondering how did we get to this point, we're
20 percent of Americans believe at least one
of these conspiracies. It was a long process,
decades of the Republican war on education.
You had this anti intellectual movement in
the United States with multiple, I guess we
would call them fronts or battle lines. You
had attacking education and teachers as being
liberal indoctrination, attacking college
as being liberal indoctrination, underfunding
public education at the state level. That's
one front starting to attack the credibility
of scientists and other experts. We saw this
with climate science. That's a big, big deal.
Same movement that said during the must have
been 70s. A smoking's not actually bad for
you, this type of thing. Right. Just creating
a narrative that's anti science, promoting
the idea of the wisdom of the masses so that
when something is popular, they can point
to it and say this many people wouldn't be
wrong. And then, of course, the huge infrastructure
of right wing political news media and I've
talked about this for so long, they blur the
lines between opinion and news. They always
have a counter narrative. They place what
should be nonsense conspiracies relegated
to some website. They place at the equivalent
level on debates on Fox News and Newsmax and
018 and talk radio. And this has been the
package that we've seen as the Republican
Party has gone from starting to get a little
bit racist during the civil rights era to
Reagan and starting to be anti lazy welfare
people. And then Gingrich in the early 90s,
further radicalizing them and getting away
from policy and starting to get towards personal
attacks. George W. Bush, the kind of dimwitted
dude who who was starting to go in the direction
of making the Republican Party really a party
of cultural values rather than policy. Obama
comes in and the racism coalesces. And then
we get Trump and we get Trumpy and insanity
and what we get now. So that's like forty
five years. Understand that the great sci
fi writer Isaac Asimov said, quote, There
is a cult of ignorance in the United States
and there has always been the strain of anti
intellectual ism has been a constant thread
winding its way through our political and
cultural life, nurtured by the false notion
that democracy means that my ignorance is
just as good as your knowledge, very appropriate
for what's taking place in the United States
right now. Now, I don't think people are willfully
stupid, not most people. It's a sort of death
of a thousand cuts type situation. The news
itself on right wing media gets more and more
cultish. The advertisements are increasingly
scams. Alex Jones is selling supplements and
weird cures. Fox News is selling Pelo. And
gold bars, all of this stuff requires some
gullibility, the ads you see on these channels
and the so-called news you see on these channels,
and then it just goes and goes and goes further.
And then you get a candidate like Trump who
says, let's coalesce all of the slightly gullible
people and put them together. And then that'll
bring in even more gullible people who say,
hey, look, all these people can't possibly
be wrong if they like it. So these are folks
who have completely lost their grip on reality
completely and altogether. And that's really
difficult to recover from. I'm not proposing
solutions here because I don't know what the
solution is, but that's the problem. And here
is
how it's now manifesting